so you just start a keto and your
cholesterol is off the charts
what do you do okay there's a couple
important things you need to know
number one and this was in 2018 the new
guidelines about the american heart
association
okay this is brand new they said total
cholesterol
is not significantly associated with
heart disease okay
that's the new finding they just found
out
looking at your total cholesterol
doesn't really give you a lot of
information with
in relationship to predicting heart
disease okay
that's number one number two your body
makes 75
25 comes from diet why do we need
cholesterol why does your body make it
to make hormones sex hormones
cell membranes bile to help you digest
fat
and vitamin d which is very very crucial
and this is why when people take
cholesterol
drugs that block cholesterol as in
statins
they have a lot of side effects relating
to
these right here which we're not going
to get into
now what i did is i took my wife
karen's report okay that i'm going to
show you i'm going to walk you through
this
this is an actual report done 11 15
2019 and we checked the total
cholesterol
the ldl the hdl triglycerides
and we checked several other things
because i always recommend when you get
a cholesterol test
you get an advanced lipid profile
an advanced test that measures the two
different types of
ldl okay which we're going to cover now
check this out this is what we found
her total cholesterol was 261.
normal is below 200.
so this is too high right so immediately
you're probably going to freak out
unless you understand that
this total cholesterol is not the
cholesterol that's floating
through your arteries it can't
it doesn't mix well with blood it has to
be packaged
in a protein so the total cholesterol is
really
all these other things combined okay
so we have ldl which is low density
lipo proteins because you need a protein
kind of a sac to push it through the
blood and we have high
density lipo protein okay
so really you know take the cholesterol
and just put it to the side right now
all right so we know the cholesterol is
high we also know her ldl
look at that should be below 100 it's
195.
it's more than double where it should be
hdl should be
greater than 50 because you want that
higher because that's the cholesterol
coming from the cells
back onto the liver okay it's not the
ldl
from the liver to the cells it's coming
back the other way
hers was really good 71. triglycerides
less than 100 hers were 66.
so this is where it's coming from right
here
but thank goodness we did a test that
goes a little bit deeper
and we measured two types of
ldl one is the large buoyant
type of ldl which is kind of large and
fluffy as it goes through the artery
and number two we measured the small
dense ldl
particles okay so
i want to focus on this one right here
small dense
so the way it's worded on the
cholesterol test is this right here
s d l d l dash c
standing for small density
all right here we go here's karen's
report we have her name
we have the date and we have the total
cholesterol which is
261 right check that out right there
and the second one this high ldlc that
stands for
ldl cholesterol it's 195. okay
if we take a look on the second page
right here
look at this the ldl is
2128 right but let's narrow in on this
one type of ldl sd ldl
dash c that's the small dense low
density lipoprotein this is one that's
dangerous
and it's actually 26 within the normal
range it's optimal
so guess what this means it means that
karen's
high level of ldl is not
the small dense type it is the large
buoyant type and it's the small dense
type that creates
the damage it's one of the better
markers
for predicting heart problems
it's one of the best indicators for
detecting inflammation
deep inside of the arteries all right so
let me just explain the inside of the
arteries
so i got this really good analogy from a
dr sanjay
gupta on one of his youtube videos
using a frying pan right so it's a
really great example
of what happens on the inside of your
arteries so here we have
this non-stick frying pan
okay so you fry something on here you
put some fat on there
and it doesn't stick right and you rub
it or you scratch
this and you get rid of this layer the
fat will start to stick
here's what you need to know cholesterol
is not going to affect the inside of the
arteries
unless there's first some type of
lesion some type of erosion
on the inside of the arteries where the
small dense type ldl can then
penetrate because they're small and
start developing
plaquing so the question is why did
karen have such high cholesterol
and such high ldl and also why did she
have
more of the large buoyant type versus
the small
dense type and that's simply because of
this this
comes from a high carb diet
it comes from consuming the wrong types
of foods
when you're doing a healthy version of
keto where you're doing higher fats
lower carb moderate protein guess what
you're going to get into ketosis you're
going to start burning fat
and a fat cell is composed of
mostly triglycerides and
cholesterol so that cholesterol has to
come out it has to be
mobilized so you can have certain times
or transitional periods where your
cholesterol goes up and it goes down
but as long as you keep your carbs low
you're going to get more of this type of
cholesterol
and this is why i always recommend doing
an advanced lipid profile not just your
regular
test that doesn't tell you very much
information
and so getting back to the arteries
there's various things that cause
inflammation
in addition to the glucose in the sugar
which is a kind of a most people know
that seed oils
a lot of corn oils canola soy
cottonseed oil and so many different
foods
mayonnaise salad dressings going off to
dinner
eating fried foods very inflammatory
smoking creates inflammation junk food
creates inflammation and also
when you're deficient in vitamin e and
you become deficient in vitamin e when
you start consuming
refined flour products and that would be
in the form of breads and pastas cereal
crackers biscuits things like that
you start becoming depleted of vitamin e
which is the protective
antioxidant to protect the inside of the
arteries and by the way
if you have any problems with the inside
of your artery
the best vitamin e to take is not
tocopherols it's tocatrinals
okay that's the one that you would want
to help
protect the inside of that layer so now
let's take a look inside the artery
and get a visual of what can happen
so we're looking here at the inside of
an artery
this tiny layer on the inside of the
artery is called the
endothelium and this layer controls the
tone
of your blood vessel it can increase the
blood pressure it can decrease the blood
pressure
it can make the artery thicker or more
elastic but it's
very sensitive to sugar
especially chronic sugar i'm talking
about chronic glucose
an average person in america consumes
between 250 to
350 grams of glucose
that is at least 13 to 15 times
what is normal so when you expose the
inside of your artery to that much
glucose
what's going to happen we're going to
get this oxidation effect
it's like rusting out the inside of your
arteries
now what happens next is the body's
response to an injury
we're going to get inflammation we're
going to get calcium that's going to
come in there and start
building up and start to to act as a
band-aid
we're also going to get cholesterol that
actually mixes in there and acts as a
band-aid
we're also going to get fibrous tissue
that's going to act as a band-aid
altogether this band-aid that's created
from calcium protein and cholesterol
is going to start to form a clot
and as that artery becomes more
obstructed
the blood flow backs up and you start
getting a diminished
flow of blood so what does blood do it
carries
oxygen and nutrition so now we
not only starve off oxygen to the
tissues we starve off nutrition
and if that blood vessel turns into a
capillary and ends up in the bottom of
your feet
you'll get peripheral neuropathy
numbness burning tingling
if that artery is the coronary artery
that goes to your heart
your heart muscle will start to cramp as
an
angina and eventually a heart attack
if that clot breaks off goes up to your
brain and starts shutting off oxygen
into your brain
you get a stroke and so all of this can
be completely prevented
just by getting the sugar out of the
diet
hey before you go real quick i have a
course
entitled how to bulletproof your immune
system
it's a free course i want you to take it
and here's why
here's you here is your
environment everyone
is focused on this over here avoiding
your environment but what about here
what about strengthening
your immune system that's what's missing
this
course will show you how to bulletproof
yourself and so you can tolerate and
resist your environment much better
by strengthening your own immune system
i put a link down in the description
right down below
check it out and get signed up today